it's fair to say that Brazilian
authorities should have seen this unrest
coming fliers like this had called for
an uprising against the country's new
government and on the day itself orders
to mobilize like this one were issued on
telegram at midday so officials had a
few hours after that to draft in enough
police but they didn't
trouble have been predicted on social
media but by 2 30 as crowds gathered in
the heart of Brazil's capital police
numbers were inexplicably low as you can
see from these pictures here just a few
police officers were on the line of
barriers and in that white box just a
few police vehicles by 240 the
protesters were on the Move heading
towards Congress when the mob reached
this point a confrontation occurred
between the protesters and a small
number of police officers the police
used pepper spray to try and hold the
crowd back but came under a hail of
missiles and were unable to hold their
ground the more broke through the
barriers sweeping the police aside and
overwhelm them with Superior numbers
there was nothing to stop them moving on
to attack the Congress building itself
they swept up the roads and across the
grass to assault the building smashing
Windows getting up onto the roof and
forcing their way inside were they
ransacked the place and they ran a mock
in the Congress chamber
itself
then they moved on to the presidential
Palace
now the few police there ran away
retreating into the building
the protesters own live streams capture
the moments they get inside the
presidential Palace
the next Target was this building the
Supreme Court actually also broke into
and smashed up
only by 4 pm did police reinforcements
arrive in the right kind of protective
gear a live stream shows the police and
military deploying at the presidential
Palace but by then a huge amount of
damage had been done to the government
buildings and to Brazil's Prestige and
it would take hours for authorities to
wrestle back complete control of the
situation